네. 안녕하세요. 빌사미 간다.
오늘은 강남역에
왔습니다. 제가 8개월 만에 강남역을
다시 오는 거 같은데 8개월 동안
강남역이 좀 어떻게 변했는지 오늘
제가 좀 직접가 가지고 좀 촬영해
보도록 하겠습니다. 지금 사실 이게
사람 다니는 시간대가 아니에요. 네.
그래가지고 지금 유동인과 많지 않지만
밤에는 그래도 유동인가 꽤 많거든요.
그래서 여기 이면까지도 이런 근린
생활 시설이 좀 많이 올라와 있고
그리고 요쪽 뒤쪽으로 가면 손혜진 씨
건물이 있습니다. 그래서 최근에
기사로 좀 되게 많이 나왔어요.
손해진 씨 건물 뭐 월 이자가 뭐
5천만 원이다. 뭐 엄청나게 어 대출
부담감이 되게 크다. 뭐 이런
기사들이 좀 많이 나오고 있는데
손혜진시 건물이 위치가 좀 되게 좋긴
하거든요. 바로이면 코너변에 있어서
위치가 되게 좋긴 하지만. 근데
임대료를 조금 높게 측정한 부분도
있어요. 지금 경기가 좋지 않지만.
그래서 지금 뭐 네이버 부동산을 봤을
때 1층 면적이 한 37평 정도
되는데 월 임대료가 한 2,200
정도 되더라고요. 그래서 평당
임대료로 봤을 때 무려 거의 60만
원에 육박합니다. 그래서 60만
원이라고 하면 아마 감이 안 오실 것
같은데 도산대로 변에 있는 건물
1층도 한 그 정도 하는 거 같아요.
그 명품 거리에 있는 바샤 커피점이
한 그 정도에 들어와 있습니다. 어
정말 저 정도의 임대가 맞춰질지
지켜보면 좋을 것 같습니다. 그래서
한번 직접 가서 한번 좀 건물을
보도록 하시죠.
그리고 요건물도 1층이랑 지하가 비어
있네요. 그래서 지금 이것처럼 지금
상권이 완벽하게 회복은 안 된 상태긴
합니다. 작년 데이터로 봤을 때 강남
중대 영상과 공실률이 한 10% 정도
된다라고 하더라고요. 또 아직도 되게
공실이 좀 높은 상태라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 그래서 이쪽으로 돌면은
이제 손혜진 씨 건물이 있는데
244억에 매입을 했어요. 그래서
이제 신축을 한 건물이고 아마 뭐
신축비랑 다 감안해서 거의 뭐 한
280억 300억에 육박하는 비용이
들지 않았을까 그렇게 예상을 하고
있습니다. 지금 공사 좀 막바지
작업인 거 같아요. 근데 상부층은
뭔가 임대가 된 거 같은 느낌이기도
[음악]
합니다. 네. 손혜진 씨 건물 앞에
와 있는데 지금 기사도 엄청 많이
나가고 있고 그리고 네이버 부동산에
지금 임대 나와 있는 거 보니까 저는
당연히 비어 있을 줄 알았는데 실제로
와서 보니까 인테리어 공사를 하고
있는 거 같아요. 그래서 아마 임대가
되지 않았을까 그렇게 예상을 합니다.
그리고 지금 제가 이렇게 육관상 봤을
때는 한 3층까지는 덕트가 설치되어
있어요. 그래서 여기가 아무래도
이면의 먹자 상권이다 보니까 이런
식당들이 좀 많이 들어옵니다. 그래서
아마 손혜진 씨 건물도 이렇게 뭐
1, 2, 3층 그래 가지고 뭐
식당이 들어오지 않을까 그렇게 좀
예상을 해 봅니다. 어, 손녀진 씨
건물은 여기까지 얘기드리고 여기 앞에
그 예전에 그 쉐버거 1호점이
들어왔던 건물이 있어요. 그래서 그
건물에 지금 1층이 비어 있습니다.
그래서 제가 비어 있는 거를 봤을 때
거의 한 최소 1년 이상 지난 그런
건물인데 그 정도로 오랜 시간 동안
비어 있어요. 여기 지금 오랫동안
비어 있는 이유 중에 하나가 가장
큰게 임대료가 매우 비쌉니다. 그래서
지금 임대 광고하고 있는 가격이
보증금 50억에 월세가 무려 1억
5천입니다. 그래서 그 정도로 평당
임대가도 되게 높아요. 거의 한 8,
90만 원, 거의 100만 원이
육박하는 그 금액에 임대가 나와 있다
보니까 1년 넘게 지금 공실로 이어져
오고 있습니다. 그리고 지금이
핵식보어 같은 경우에는 비건물로
이전을 했어요. 비 건물은 월
임대료가 한 1억 정도라고 합니다.
그래서 이거 여기보다는 상대적으로
저렴하기 때문에 저쪽으로 이동하지
않았나 그렇게 좀 예상을 합니다.
그리고 저기 뒤에 보이는 저기
성형에과 건물 보이시죠? 그래서 저게
최근에 매각이 됐는데 어 돼지가
그렇게 안 큽니다. 한 돼지간 64평
정도 되고 최근에 매각된 금액이 무려
530억입니다. 그래서 대시 평단가로
봤을 때는 8억이 넘는 금액이에요.
그래서 그 정도로 여기가 평단가가
되게 높습니다. 여기 강남도로에서
최고가를 찍은 그런 건물이라고 보시면
될 거 같아요. 뭐 위치도 위치인데
어 땅의 크기 그리고 나중에 액시 할
것까지 생각을 한다면 만약에 저게
530억에 샀을 때 나중에 이제
600억 700억 그 이상의 매각을
해야 되는데 아무래도 면적에 한계가
있다 보니까뭐 나중에 좀 어떻게
될지도 한번 좀 지켜보면 좋을 거
같아요. 그래서 저기 지금 강남대로의
최고가에 매각된 사례도 한번 좀 계속
지켜보시면 좋을 거 같고 그래서 오늘
제가 뭐 매각 사례도 좀 설명드렸고
그리고 지금 인대 시장이 물론 이제
전에 이제 한 8개월 전에 왔을
때보다는 조금 좋아지긴 했어요. 이제
조금 임대도 들어와 있고 조금 변화가
있긴 하지만 아직 완벽하게 회복된
상태는 아닌 거 같습니다. 그래서
여러분들 강남역 상권도 계속 좀
유심히 지켜보면 좋을 거 같고 그럼
지금 시간이 점심 시간쯤 됐는데네
그래서 여기 이면에 인근 상권도 한번
좀 보고 한번 직접 식당도 한번 가서
어떻게 변화되는지 한번 직접 보도록
하겠습니다. 가시죠.
[음악]
뭐 여기 지금 대로변도 그렇고 예전에
진짜 대로변에 저렇게 공실난 건물을
본 적이 없거든요. 뭐 코로나 이후에
뭐 경기가 더 좀 악화되면서 좀
공실들도 많이 생겨났고 근데 이제
임대료를 사실 내리기 좀 쉽진
않아요. 건물주 입장에서. 어,
아무래도 건물 가격이나 이런 거에 큰
영향을 끼치기 때문에 뭐 지금도 이제
뭐 둘러봤을 때 뭐 1층 비어 있는
데가 그래도 꽤 있는 모습을 좀
보였습니다. 그리고 여기 이면으로도
뭐 거의 다 차 있긴 하지만 그래도
좀 뭐 비어 있는 건물들도 꽤 있었고
그래서 아무래도 지금 뭐 경기 자체가
좀 좋지 않다 보니까 아직 강남역
상권이 그렇게 활발이 좀 부활하거나
어 그러진 않은 상태인 거 같습니다.
근데 이와 비교해서 지금 핫한 곳
있잖아요. 지금 저희가 뭐 성수동 뭐
연무장길이라든지 막 이런 데는 임대를
해 보면 정말 깜짝 놀랄 정도로 일단
너무 잘 되고 그래서 말도 안 되게
지금 뭐 인대료 가격이 계속 올라가고
있고 그래서 앞구정 로데오도 비슷한데
근데 지금 요즘 상황에서는 앞구정
로데오보다는 진짜 성수동 그 연무장길
일대가 정말 임대료 수준뿐만 아니라
공실률도 거의 없습니다. 이제 앞으로
또 상권이 좀 계속 이러지 않을까
싶어요. 그리 아파트도 뭐
원베일리라든지 이런 좀 유명한
아파트들은 계속 최고가 경신하고
있잖아요.이 빌딩 거래뿐만 아니라
이런 상권도 되게 양극화가 심해지고
있다. 네. 이렇게 좀 생각을
합니다. 그리고 저 개인적으로는 향후
이제 10년 뒤 뭐 20년 뒤를 봤을
때 강남역이랑 삼성역이랑 비교를 하면
저는 삼성역이 좀 더 콘텐츠적으로론
좀 더 많지 않을까? 네. 이렇게 좀
조심스럽게 예상을 하는데 일단은
영동대로 공원화도 있고 거기 일대가
되게 걸어다니고 볼 만한게 되게 더
많아질 것 같아요. 그리고 거기
코엑스 밑에만 가더라도 지하에 웬만한
식당이라든지 뭐 쇼핑할 곳이라든지 뭐
그런게 워낙 잘 돼 있기 때문에 저는
앞으로 사람들이 강남을 온다라고 하면
삼성력에 좀 더 쏠림이 있지 않을까?
네. 이렇게 좀 조심스럽게 예상을
하고 있습니다. 거기 일대 이런
정광판들도 되게 많잖아요. 한국에 뭐
타임스퀘어를 만들겠다 뭐 이런
얘기들이 좀 있는데 그러다 보니까
외국인 관광객들도 많이 그쪽으로 좀
많이 찾는 거 같고 실제로 외국인
관광객들도 그쪽으로 좀 많이
가거든요. 물론 제 예측이 틀릴 수도
있습니다. 여러분들이 좀 지금 강남역
상권이 좀 어떻게 회복되고 어떻게
발전될지도 한번 지켜보시면 좋을 거
같고 우리 제가 말씀드린 그
삼성역대도 한번 좀 지켜보시면 좋을
것 같습니다. 네. 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요. 어, 제가 아마
강남역은 그래도 계속 좀 꾸준히
정기적으로 좀 찍을 예정이에요. 작게
한 6개월 뒤, 1년 뒤에는 좀 어떤
모습으로 변했는지 그런 모습들도 좀
생생하게 영상으로 좀 담도록
하겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 빌딩은 역시 빌사나.
Ah.